mickey dans deux jours officiellement en
france euro disney ouvre ses portes au
public dimanche on s'attend d'ailleurs
aux pires embouteillages en fait milk
est déjà là et plusieurs milliers de
privilégiés aux mamies ont même pu se
rendre sur le nouveau site de marne la
vallée c'est une région d'ailleurs qui a
été complètement transformée par
l'arrivée des américains eric lemasson
derniers préparatifs et résumé des
chapitres précédents
l'endroit s'appeler les trois petits
bois les regards les longues raies
gabriel vanhonacker y était né à la
place de ces chants 12000 places de
parking et des trottoirs roulants qui
mène désormais vers adventure land
cheyenne hôtel ou santa fe
qui tue un peu de tout la céréale et
puis des
dés
des betteraves ici à peu près l'endroit
où on se trouve
j'ai tué mon premier lieu à l'âge de 10
ans c'était un peu de la braconne
tout près de là le nouveau maître des
lieux fraîchement venue de californie
dans son jet privé flanqué de ses deux
gardes du corps cet homme vaut 450
millions de dollars de revenus par an
son nom michael eisner le big boss de la
walt disney company euro disneyland est
l'aboutissement de sa réussite il semble
bien loin le temps tout proche pourtant
ou michael eisner réussissait à
convaincre deux premier ministre de la
france de s'associer à son projet
laurent fabius en 85 jacques chirac en
87h nerfs obtiendra des deux que la
france mise quatre fois plus d'argent
dans l'industrie du rêve que la walt
disney company elle même pour mickey la
france allait se montrer généreuse deux
échangeurs d'autoroute une ligne rer une
gare tgv des prêts bonifiés une tva
minimale facture 4 milliards de francs
oublié aussi les temps des polémiques et
du conflit avec les sous traitants
digérer enfin les oeufs et les tomates
pourries des jeunesses communistes lors
de l'introduction en bourse d'euro
disneyland aujourd'hui l'action figure
dans le cac 40 l'indicé des valeurs de
référence
implacable la machine disney a fait son
oeuvre sur le petit coin de terre
briarde quatre ans seulement c'est par
cette image de celle du dernier coup de
pinceau hier au royaume enchanté entre
temps une ville entière est sorti de
terre 5200 chambre d'hôtel 50
attractions des dizaines de boutiques
tout est prêt pour que l'argent enfin
rentrer dans les caisses une armée de
journalistes du monde entier est
attendue gabriel lui même semble conquis
gérer dans le parc en genre quand
j'aurais le temps j'irais j'irai
mes enfants ils sont déjà les jacques
chirac hui sera présent à l'inauguration
dimanche en 1987 lors de la signature du
contrat michael eisner lui avait fait un
cadeau un dessin original de blanche
neige recevant la pomme empoisonnée
pas de panique au royaume de mickey
depuis 48 heures certains avaient fait
monter la pression vous le savez on
annonce en une journée de cauchemar sur
les routes qui mènent à eurodisneyland
apparemment il n'en a rien été les
responsables de chez disney avait tout
prévu et les automobilistes ont fait
preuve de beaucoup de sagesse première
journée est racontée par eric lemasson
et frédéric de la rue
[Applaudissements]
jetté cre a
officiellement ouvert
cela faisait cinq ans que le compte à
rebours avait été déclenchée pour le 12
avril 92 à 9h01 mais la perfection même
chez disney n'est pas de ce monde euro
disney land a ouvert ses portes ce matin
avec une heure d'avancé 20 à 30000
visiteurs pour cette journée qualifiée
d' historique parmi eux les gallier de
villepin une famille sélectionnée pour
être les premiers visiteurs récompense
du marketing disney un abonnement à vie
il va venir tous les jours matin et un
ticket
mais jouera chez pas parce que j'ai
connu je vais peut-être bien mais
week-end
entre deux attractions la première
parade spectacle incontournable des
parcs disney
une fois par jour un concentré de 60 ans
d'histoire du dessin animé
le ciel s'est couvert sur marne la
vallée mais l'illusion fonctionne euro
disneyland et la réplique fidèle du
modèle américain le climat en moins à
cause du temps vous partez déjà ries
appelait par cissé parfait fabuleux il
fait trop froid
c'est génial et surtout en arts et
sciences
partners
jeune troupe à ce que ça vaut la peine
d'y aller quand même
c'est pour tout le monde sait que j'ai
62 ans j'ai doit aussi gérer et ce
maillage oui combien de kilomètres
ont-ils parcouru combien de temps et ils
patientaient dans les files d'attentes
des attractions le rêve est à ce prix
demain ils prendront le métro pour aller
au boulot
[Musique]